من ضجيج الشارع السوداني الذي لم يهدا الى
انسداد سياسيين خيمه هو الاخر على المشهد
في البلاد منذ الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر
العام الماضي تخرج جهود محليه ودوليه سعيا
وراء حل لينهل المازق الذي تمر به البلاد
فعلى الطريق اتفاق الايطالي جديد يجمع بين
المكونين المدني والعسكري يركز الاتفاق
على المبادئ العامه وقضايا ومهام الانتقال
وهياكل الفتره الانتقاليه اضافه الى
الاجهزه النظاميه وانتهاء بقضايا الاتفاق
النهائي التي سيبدا النقاش حولها بشكل
موسع مع اصحاب المصلحه
على همم هم القضايا التي ستتناولها الفتره
الانتقاليه من الاصلاح الامني والاصلاح
الاقتصادي ووضع الانتخابات ووضع قانون
للانتخابات مع همم وضع الدستور الدائم همم
للسودان خلال الفتره الانتقاليه
الى وثيقه الكل يشرع انه جزء من هذه
الوثيقه وانه ساهم فيه وان هذا الوثيقه
مملوكه الشعب السوداني وليس للطرف من
الاطراف
شوط ثاني من الاتفاق سياسي اخر قد يجمع
ولو جزءا من فرق سياسه على امل انهاء
الازمه السياسيه التي تعيشها البلاد
عصام عبد السلام العربيه